robbing for any actor who wants to be a
working actor in Hollywood what are some
things that they need to know about not
just the business but also themselves
you have to have a good sense of
yourself and a good thick skin it's very
odd that an actor needs to be able to
shed that skin immediately and be able
to be vulnerable and express feelings
but you must have thick skin because you
are going you're not going to get more
jobs than you do get even the most
famous actors the ones you think work
all the time don't get every job they
want and as a working actor we working
actors don't get more jobs than we do so
you have to know that you just have to
know that and then you have to act I
encouraged alas equity is making this a
little more difficult for equity actors
but if but you have to perform so find a
class to go to that keeps your your
instrument lubricated and working so you
know it you're not going in and trying
to read for Macbeth after not doing
anything for you know six months or
doing you know cereal commercials you
have so find a workshop someplace where
you can work and do scenes and scene
study and that sort of thing be very
careful of becoming a professional
student a lot of people come here and
take start taking classes and they and
that satisfies them in a way you know
being you know doing even doing really
good work in class is not the same as
working and so I you have to do that
work in order to be able to be good
enough to land work so you have to get
on stage as as often as you can there
are lots of little theaters here the do
plays again equities if you're not
equity you can do that if you are equity
you have to do some workarounds to get
that happening now alas but but get on
stage as much as you can so you're
warmed up you should
always before you go out on an audition
you should be as prepared as you can
possibly be but for yourself again this
is not so much about the audition but
for the person go somewhere in public
before you go to the audition jump
because you need to you're a human who
is trying to display human emotions and
if you make this audition the most
important thing of your day that this is
your getting ready for this I can't do
anything before this I have to do this
is the focus focus the focus then you
get in the room and you're not limber
yeah you know so I always try to go and
have a cup of coffee or pick up my
dry-cleaning or chat with you know
somebody go get something from the
market do something so I'm limber and
I've I've I've had a conversation with
someone before I'm having my first
conversation with you with a casting
director who holds my future in your
heads so that's one thing that I think
is very important and then on the flip
side of that at the end of the audition
go somewhere fun reward yourself you
know have something to look forward to
because a lot of times if you go in you
can tell you can read the room whether
you get whether they received you well
or not you can't always tell because
there have been times when I've gone in
and thought that i stunk up the room and
got a call a few hours later saying I
booked the job so you can't really judge
by that but but if you've made the
audition or the interview the most
important moment of your day then you're
very likely to feel this huge letdown at
the end of it or this artificial sort of
stiffness at the beginning of it because
you haven't been a person you know so
thankfully so those I think are the most
important things because everybody has
different levels of talent so you know I
can't really speak to that but but those
things you have to understand that
you're not going to get more jobs than
you do you have to understand that
nobody gets your job you get your job
and never talked about having lost a job
when it was only an audition you didn't
lose anything you can't lose anything
you didn't have and and go out somewhere
before the audition to limber up and
have somewhere fun to go
the audition to celebrate because you
went to work absolutely love that in
terms of interacting with people yeah
losing that sort of social phobia that
we all cuz we're all in a hurry we're
like well I don't have much time and
it's gonna be traffic and now la is a
little more crowded than it wants to be
so we're even more like dialed in on
just going directly to where we used to
but like go somewhere fun like Trader
Joe's and exactly yeah just rishabh are
they they're the girls or something just
make something dad live you know do
something to get yourself personalized
again right right instead of focused on
the job let's talk about once you get
the job how should one conduct
themselves on set even if they're just
they're just I have a scene where
they're gonna cross it from the camera
or they have several lines of dialogue
first of all the crew is usually
comprised of real people who are not
full of themselves and are willing to
share information with you you know meet
your ad who's gonna tell you where the
dressing rooms are and be nice to the
craft service person and be nice to
everyone but here's one thing that you
must know for sure if someone of the
regular cast is nice to you and reaches
out to you it will be a rarity I am
amazed at the number of people who have
every reason to be kind and open to the
guest stars or co-stars who come on the
show who won't even give them the time
of day and so just don't expect it don't
expect that you be nice
take care of yourself you be kind if
someone is nice and sweet to you be nice
and sweet back but don't try to suddenly
become their best friend because that's
just going to backfire on you in a major
way and ask questions feel free to ask
questions if you need to ask questions
but don't expect that you are going to
be embraced into the company because it
doesn't happen very often I'm unless
it's my show because what I make sure
that I do that because I know how
difficult it can be to be the day player
on a set or the one in
three days or something and I've always
made it a point to welcome I think
that's probably the theater thing again
that you know the pas de Chile and the
glass of wine concept but that's what
they should do and be on time always be
on time it's a good idea to bring a
magazine or a book and a comfy pillow
with you have a little set bag because
you spend a lot of time waiting and you
want to be comfortable when you do and
most of the trailers or dressing rooms
don't have a comfy pillow or reading
material for you to pass the time with
you know if you have any kind of special
dietary needs or prohibitions make take
care of make sure you take care of
yourself in that regard bring your bring
a snack or two that fits those things
and be prepared to wait and and check
you know if you feel like you've been
waiting a really long time and you're
kind of losing the edge check with your
ad and and find out if you know how was
it likely can you give me an ETA
I'd like 15 minutes before you need me
if at all possible you may not be able
to get that 15 minutes but that's why
you say if at all possible and you could
remember I'd love to just so I can pump
up you know it for when it's time to go
and and know your lines and and you know
be prepared to enjoy yourself and do a
good job I like what you said too about
you know be friendly but not trying to
be someone's best friend right and then
on the flip side knowing that people
that oh I can't wait to work with
so-and-so and know that they may not see
you and not being hurt perfectly said
you know because I think there's like
this armor we have to wear and I think
you learn it after a few years of being
here but when you're new especially you
get really it's easy to get hurt or it's
easily become someone's best friend
right away and then find out you never
hear from them again right but you can
you talk about that armor and it's not
being a mean person it's just being
protective yeah but I also
so it's not being a mean person but I
you are more generous than I in this
regard I find that it is that they are
not being a conscious person okay mm-hmm
you know if you don't if you can't say
hello welcome to the show yeah nice to
have you now one of the reasons they may
not do that is because when they have
done that the newbie has decided that oh
now she's my best friend I would have
talked right everyone have lunch
together and everything and and that
person wants you know get off of me you
know I don't I'm just maybe they're
protecting themselves because they've
done this before
and or and it kind of backfired on them
in a way that they didn't want to have
to deal with true however it is easy to
take a moment to welcome someone to your
show to to be kind to them to have a
nice word because we are all doing it
together everybody is in the same boat
you know you have a better seat perhaps
than I do if you're the regular on the
show but we're in the same boat and
we're all actors and performers so I
find that I find that sort of treatment
I was doing an episode of and so she was
while the makeup lady was doing her
makeup her face was down like this in
her cell phone the whole time she didn't
speak to anyone
she didn't say now she may be a
perfectly lovely girl I worked with her
for a week she seemed very nice on the
set but if I use that as an example of
how you as a guest star co-star should
be or any star should be on the show is
that the people that are there the
makeup the hair they're not your
servants they're professionals who are
doing their job treat them with dignity
and with respect because they have
control over how you look you're allowed
to say I prefer to have my hair blown
forward rather than blown back or I
would like to have it up if possible
blah blah blah you can tell them what it
is you want but do it as though you
Artie speaking to a professional and say
please and thank you and be a conscious
human being
well you know don't they're not your
staff sure
you